I was brought up on my - great great  twelve hours but so much so glad it  happened to me at the age of nineteen  people should be rushing into this that  you guys are ready to find it was  wonderful fantastic is unbelievable but  I know the Lord has done it fantastic  information or practical pragmatic  believable and it just shows how much  good property there are there is out  there to invest in there's options all  over the moat it's great  in excess of 50% returned awesome what  is your return on investment  Samuel eat is awesome high-energy very  very practical day something that can  use today and tomorrow and for the rest  of my life great value